was victim of that particular political
mania all right a change in the party
major thank you very much
the top u.s general in afghanistan says
the next two weeks will be critical for
the ongoing withdrawal of u.s led
coalition forces in an exclusive cbs
news interview general scott miller
spoke with charlie dagetta about the
challenges
u.s troops and afghan forces face amid a
wave of taliban attacks
try managing this in 40 mile an hour
crosswinds
packing materials destined for us bases
just part of the heavy lift in a mission
to draw down
the last 2 500 or so us troops in
afghanistan
an historic turning point under the
watch of general scott miller it's going
very well and in some cases ahead of
schedule
after almost 20 years of a continuous
american presence here dismantling it
all
is a mammoth task it's not just about
safeguarding the withdrawal of
u.s troops it's weapons equipment
machinery
an entire infrastructure all while
trying to defend against taliban
militants determined to settle scores
as u.s soldiers head for the exits have
you
had any trouble from the taliban do you
anticipate any trouble from the taliban
the to date we've seen a uh a couple
incidents
of taliban activity against the
coalition we have the military means and
capabilities here to defend ourselves as
well as the afghan security forces
capabilities like u.s airstrikes
launched after a taliban attack on a u.s
base in the south and taliban fighters
advancing against
afghan forces as one may commenced we
saw a pretty
pretty large surge of taliban violence
across the country
in provinces we expected general miller
knows the taliban playbook by
heart just over a month after he took
command he drew his sidearm when a rogue
afghan bodyguard
opened fire on their delegation killing
an afghan lieutenant general
and wounding a u.s brigadier general
a former delta force captain miller was
one of the first american soldiers on
the ground in the u.s
invasion following 9 11. now
america's longest war is being brought
to an end
by america's longest serving commander
in afghanistan
had you anticipated being here this long
absolutely not in 2001 i
i don't ever think i could project 20
years later
and see that we'd be standing here
general miller paid tribute not only to
the americans who are still here but the
tens of thousands who came before
especially